Trascrizione: Alessio Fresca
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Chi di voi si ricorda di Star Trek?
Da bambino trascorrevo ore intere
a vedere questa serie tv di fantascienza,
con la sua navicella USS Enterprise,
il cui modellino conservavo,
gelosamente, nella mia camera.
Comandata dal mitico capitano Kirk,
che sfrecciava nello spazio
alla ricerca di nuovi mondi
e nuove frontiere.
Oggi, neanche qualche mese fa,
all'età di 90 anni,
il capitano Kirk è riuscito nell'intento
di volare davvero nello spazio,
come passeggero a bordo
di una navicella spaziale.
Oggi tutti possono andare nello spazio,
perché l'accesso allo spazio è cambiato.
Come voi saprete, in questi ultimi tempi
sulla scena internazionale
sono comparsi degli attori privati:
Virgin Galactic;
Blue Origin; Sierra Nevada.
Operatori privati
in grado di trasportare nello spazio,
come nel caso della missione
"Inspiration 4", dello scorso anno;
o della missione Ax-1 di aprile.
Normali cittadini
che non solo non appartengono
a nessuna agenzia spaziale,
non sono nemmeno
astronauti professionisti:
very normal people.
Il paradosso è che, negli ultimi mesi
hanno volato più persone comuni
che veri astronauti.
Ma come si è arrivati,
a questo cambio di paradigma?
Per capire l'evoluzione,
vorrei ripercorrere con voi
alcune tappe che hanno portato
a questo cambio epocale.
12 aprile 1981.
Il primo space shuttle viene lanciato
dal "Kennedy Space Center", in Florida.
Capolavoro di ingegneria:
era il primo veicolo riutilizzabile
della storia della astronautica,
che ritornava sulla Terra
atterrando su una pista
come i normali aeroplani,
e poi ridecollava
per una successiva missione.
8 luglio 2011:
ultima missione dello Space Shuttle,
Atlantis, chiamata STS 135.
Il programma, sotto
l'amministrazione Obama,
viene cancellato:
il sistema di trasporto
non era più sostenibile né affidabile.
Ogni volo dello Shuttle costava
circa 1.000.000.000 di dollari a missione,
e in 135 missioni il programma
aveva contato ben 14 vittime,
e la perdita di due velivoli.
Intanto i russi, con la Soyuz,
un razzo molto più affidabile -
nessuna perdita -
ed economico - circa 240 milioni
di dollari a missione -
dispongono dal 2011 al 2020
dell'unico veicolo spaziale
in grado di trasportare degli astronauti
sulla Stazione Spaziale Internazionale.
E gli americani, con quel loro
innato intuito per il business,
approfittano di questo taxi
estremamente efficiente.
La meta è sempre quella:
la Stazione Spaziale Internazionale -
o ISS, International Space Station.
La casa dell'Umanità nello Spazio:
o, come molti hanno sottolineato,
il più grosso esperimento
diplomatico mai esistito.
Perché in questo laboratorio scientifico
a 400 chilometri di altezza,
e che sfreccia alla velocità
di 27.000 chilometri orari,
astronauti professionisti americani,
russi, canadesi, giapponesi ed europei
convivono tutti in spazi ristretti,
effettuano esperimenti in assenza di peso
e si addestrano alle missioni
spaziali del futuro.
30 maggio 2020, data storica.
Gli americani escono allo scoperto
e ritornano nello spazio
in maniera autonoma,
con il lancio della modernissima
"Crew Dragon Demo 2"
di SpaceX, azienda appartenente
al magnate Elon Musk.
Badate bene, è questa
la differenza fondamentale:
un privato, non più il governo.
Si apre ufficialmente l'era
del volo spaziale commerciale,
che apre degli scenari mai visti finora.
Una rivoluzione copernicana
non solo per il sistema di trasporto,
ma anche per la creazione
di una struttura orbitante e privata,
che avrà diverse funzioni:
una stazione spaziale commerciale
di nuova generazione,
più grande, più moderna;
un laboratorio scientifico
per fare esperimenti in microgravità;
oppure un'infrastruttura residenziale
in grado di ospitare
sia l'astronauta professionista,
che il privato che si vuole concedere
un'esperienza veramente unica,
ovvero utilizzarla proprio
come un albergo nello spazio.
Vi starete chiedendo: ma fra quanti anni
succederà tutto questo?
Esiste, in America,
una ditta qualificata da NASA
come l'unica che costruirà
la prima stazione spaziale commerciale,
con il lancio del primo
modulo abitativo nel 2024,
a cui seguiranno altri moduli
che verranno assemblati
come un sistema di Lego,
per completarla nel 2028,
prima che l'attuale ISS,
al termine della sua vita operativa,
venga deorbitata,
facendola precipitare
nel cimitero spaziale,
quello che in gergo
viene chiamato Punto Nemo,
ubicato nel mezzo dell'Oceano Pacifico.
Lo spazio oggi è veramente per tutti.
Cambiando l'accesso,
cambia anche l'esigenza:
e questo apre il campo
a nuove e variegate opportunità.
Fino ad oggi,
tutti noi abbiamo immaginato lo spazio,
e tutto ciò che circonda lo spazio,
come un contenitore:
il razzo che consente
di trasportare gli astronauti
dalla Terra, come un ascensore,
verso lo spazio;
la stazione in grado
di ospitare gli esseri viventi.
Ma non ci siamo mai soffermati
sull'aspetto dei contenuti,
ovvero di tutte quelle cose
che vengono portate insieme ai razzi,
ma che sono altrettanto indispensabili:
e che vanno dal cibo al vestiario,
dagli equipaggiamenti
di controllo medico ai farmaci,
dagli strumenti di igiene
e cosmesi personale al wellness.
Immaginatevi che cosa potreste fare,
in questa nuova infrastruttura.
Potreste prenotare un soggiorno
con camera con vista
mozzafiato sulla Terra,
o sull'infinità dello spazio cosmico;
potreste, per far colpo
sul vostro partner,
riservare un tavolo per due
al ristorante vicino alla cupola,
dove verranno serviti
non più i poco allettanti
cibi liofilizzati stile anni '80,
ma prelibatezze - possibilmente italiane -
e preparate con ingredienti coltivati
nell'adiacente serra spaziale,
e dove si berrà un eccellente prosecco,
magari prodotto proprio da queste parti.
Dovrete fare almeno due ore
di attività motoria al giorno,
per evitare l'atrofia muscolare
causata dalla microgravità,
in una palestra dotata
di tutti i confort necessari,
utilizzando attrezzature moderne
che sappiano combinare
l'intrattenimento digitale
con una vista senza eguali.
E questo sarà solo
l'inizio di un'avventura
che vedrà le infrastrutture orbitanti
come il trampolino di lancio
verso nuove mete:
la colonizzazione della Luna o di Marte,
che consentiranno alla civiltà umana
di sviluppare insediamenti
dove vivere per settimane,
mesi o addirittura anni.
Ma tutto ciò può essere fine a se stesso?
In che relazione stanno,
lo spazio e la Terra?
La sfida è sicuramente molto affascinante,
perché lo spazio impone delle costrizioni
con cui confrontarci ogni giorno,
che vanno dall'assenza di gravità,
dalla scarsità dell'acqua,
che è una risorsa preziosissima,
alla necessità di dover riciclare
tutti i rifiuti inorganici,
perché quello che si porta dalla Terra
ha un peso e un costo
enorme da sopportare.
Quanti di voi hanno pensato,
oppure hanno spesso
sentito dire, ultimamente:
"Abbiamo un solo pianeta" oppure
"L'umanità è a rischio di estinzione".
E sulla base di queste affermazioni
vengono fatte le più assurde
stime temporali
per consentire all'uomo
di fuggire dalla terra
e iniziare a colonizzare altri pianeti,
come estrema soluzione per evitare
questa tragica e inesorabile sorte.
È vero: sì, un solo pianeta,
la nostra terra,
se pensiamo unicamente
in termini di ottimizzazione
dello sfruttamento delle risorse.
Ma se cominciamo a ragionare in ottica
di innovazione e ottimizzazione,
lo spazio può fare molto,
per la sostenibilità di un solo pianeta.
Ed è proprio da lassù
che nasceranno nuove idee
che consentiranno di rendere migliore
la qualità della nostra vita sulla terra,
e rendere migliore
il futuro dei suoi abitanti.
Non c'è limite a quello che si può fare,
nello spazio senza limiti:
l'impossibile ha solo bisogno
di un momento in più.
Grazie.
(Applausi)